GRADY POWELL: Bladesmiths,
congratulations.
You're moving forward in
the third and final round
of our competition
where we're sending you
back to your home
forges to build
an iconic weapon from history.
Now I'm going to apologize
in advance because I
didn't choose this blade.
That was up to J.
[uptempo music]
Bladesmiths, you didn't think
I was going to start taking
it easy on you now, did you?
No.
I want you to build this.
Mindanao Kris.
[sighs]
The Mindanao Kris traces its
origin back to the 14th century
Mindanao, the second largest
island in the Philippines.
This double-edged
sword is defined
by its distinct waves
designed to inflict
wide, deadly slashes in combat.
[splattering]
The amount of waves in
the warrior's weapon
also indicates their
status within the tribe.
The more waves, the
higher the rank.
The Kris was the most
common moro sword
and many can be seen today
in museums across the world,
including the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York City.
GRADY POWELL: You'll have
four days at your home
forge to build your blades.
Good luck, gentlemen,
when we see you then.
All right.
Good luck.
[uptempo music]
JOHN BLANKMAN: I'm John
Blankman from Avon, Utah.
I'm a fire sprinkler contractor.
I like bladesmithing because,
at this point in my life,
I'm stuck behind a desk
most of the time and this
allows me to get back out
and do things with my hands
and it's just fulfilling.
And they're throwing
curves at us.
Curves are not my thing.
I haven't done them, but
I am pretty confident I
can get this thing done.
So we're going to start
getting the curves
into the blade itself,
then taking a lot of weight
off of it.
For now I set up some jigs
to get these curves bent
into the blade.
So at any given
moment when you're
putting these radical
of a bend in it,
your steel could rip
and have a tear in it.
You got to kind of
cross your fingers
that you're doing it right.
That should work.
So the blade's come
along really nice.
It's in pretty good shape
where I want it to be.
Oh, crap.
Got a little bit
of a crack here.
Seriously?
If I can't get this crack
ground out, then this is junk.
OK.
Finally, I get to the bottom
of it and it is still saveable
and I don't have to start over.
Things are going
along pretty good.
Trying to get the blade
polished up a little bit,
get the handle put onto
it, got to get it etched,
and finish it up.
Looking good.
All right, got it
all sharpened up.
Let's go out and give
her a quick test.
I'm feeling great about
what I've accomplished.
I do you believe
that's all I can do.
DALE BRANNIGAN:
I'm Dale Brannigan
from Shelby, North Carolina.
I design technology
systems for banks
and financial institutions.
I like forging for the escape.
I get to hit things with
hammers and play with fire.
[laughs]
Steel's moving slow.
Press is a little weak.
Keeps bending it
all over the place,
so I have to keep
straightening it out.
We're getting there.
That's starting to
look like a Kris.
Handle material is pretty
close to shape already.
All right.
The handle is glued
up, the epoxy is set.
Doesn't look bad.
Now I'm going to wrap
the handle with hemp.
It's not a requirement,
but it'll give a good grip
and it looks kind of cool.
I have a completed weapon.
Just to turn in something
complete at the end
of these rounds
is kind of a feat,
so I'm super happy
that I'm done.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your Kris and
deliver some lethal blows
on this pig carcass.
John, you're first.
Are you ready for this?
You bet.
All right, let's do this.
[building music]
[thudding]
Sweet.
All right, John.
Let's talk about your
Mindanao Kris here.
I really appreciate that
you have this large flare
because it's a very
forward heavy blade,
but because of that weight and
a very sharp edge you have here,
these are very, very deep
cuts on this pig carcass.
It'll kill.
[laughs]
Cool.
Dale, your turn,
so are you ready?
That's what I'm here for.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, let's do this.
[heavy metal music]
[thudding]
Neat, man.
Good job.
[suspenseful music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Dale, let's talk
about your Mindanao Kris.
First up, it's a lot lighter.
Now that allows
me to use velocity
to cut down a pig like this
with the same amount of strikes.
The edge will cut deeply and,
overall sir, your weapon it
will kill.
Awesome.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
One of my personal favorites,
the ice block chop.
I'm going to take
your Kris swords
and try to free those masks.
We're going to have some fun.
John, you're up first.
You ready to go?
I am.
Go make snow cones.
Well, we could do that.
[heavy metal music]
[grunting]
[laughs]
Damn.
[suspenseful music]
Nice work, John.
Love the Damascus.
Very heavy.
It tears through the eyes, but
if the ice block was any bigger
it'd be tearing through me, too.
And you got a bit of a
warp, but still razor sharp.
Good job.
Thanks.
Dale, you ready to go?
If anybody's going to break my
sword it might as well be you.
Good.
I appreciate that.
Let's do it.
[heavy metal music]
[grunting]
[suspenseful music]
Dale, nice job.
The only complaint I have
is your wrap here is loose,
but everything's still
tight, your edge is good.
Nice job.
Thanks, J.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness
test, the palm slice.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I'm going to take
your Mindanao Krises
and try to cut
through these palms.
John you are first.
You ready for this?
I am.
[suspenseful music]
[heavy metal music]
Nice.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, John, let's talk
about your weapon here.
First up, your edge
is still very sharp.
It's just that the weight of
this has me holding on to it
because I don't want
this to be flying around.
But for this particular
test, it will cut.
Thank you.
Dale, your turn,
so are you ready?
Slice it up.
All right, will do.
[suspenseful music]
[heavy metal music]
All right, Dale, let's talk
about your Mindanao Kris here.
It's thin and razor sharp.
Definitely the type of edge you
want in cutting these brushes.
And overall, sir, your
edge, it will cut.
Thanks, Doug.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
bladesmiths, before we
get into the hard part, I want
to say it's been a pleasure
watching both of you guys work.
There's been a lot of twists
and turns and J's challenge,
but this is a competition and
there's only one champion.
The "Forged in Fire"
champion today is--
[suspenseful music]
--Dale.
Congratulations.
John, you did a fantastic job,
but, unfortunately, your Kris
isn't going to end
up on the wall.
Your time in this
competition has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
All right.
It's been a great
experience, man.
GRADY POWELL: Thank you, John.
J. NEILSON: Thank you, John.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Thank you, John.
- Appreciate it.
Great job, John.
JOHN BLANKMAN: This whole
journey with "Forged in Fire"
has been incredible.
[laughs]
GRADY POWELL: Well, Dale,
congratulations, man.
That means you are the
newest "Forged in Fire"
champion you just won
yourself a check for $10,000.
Well done.
[applause]
I'm blown away.
Super proud.
Literally the day
before I started
that was five years to the day
that I lit my first forge--
No kidding.
DALE BRANNIGAN: --so--
DOUG MARCAIDA: Who knew
five years later you'd
be a "Forged in Fire" champ?
Everybody who knows
that you make knives asks,
when are you going to
be on "Forged in Fire?"
Now I can tell
them, not only have
I been on "Forged in Fire," but
I won a J. Nielsen challenge.
[uptempo music]